une crise sanitaire qui se transforment
en crises politiques économiques et
sociales dans les rues de quito capitale
de l'équateur et malgré l'interdiction
des autorités
ils sont plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
et de travailleurs à s'être rassemblés
ce vendredi pour dénoncer la gestion de
la crise par le gouvernement
parmi eux des vendeurs de rue obligé de
travailler malgré le couvre-feu en
vigueur
[Musique]
ils ne voient pas que si nous
travaillons dans la rue c'est parce que
nous n'avons pas d'autres sources de
revenus
nous devons sortir tous les jours pour
subvenir aux besoins de nos enfants de
nos foyers
l'augmentation de la pauvreté de la
misère à les gens qui n'ont rien à
manger qui n'ont pas accès au système de
santé qui voient leur famille mourir
fait descendre les gens dans la rue et à
chaque fois il y à davantage de gens qui
marchent protestent et s'organisent les
perspectives économiques n'était déjà
pas très réjouissante avant la pandémie
depuis elles se sont encore dégradées
quelques 150 mille équatoriens ont perdu
leur emploi à cause du pur aux navires
us une crise qui a déjà coûté à
l'économie équatorienne
au moins huit milliards de dollars selon
le président moreno et d'après la banque
mondiale la croissance devrait chuter de
7 4% en 2020 une crise sanitaire
économique sociale mais aussi politique
le 9 juillet dernier le ministre des
affaires étrangères a remis sa démission
un troisième départ après ceux du vice
président et du secrétaire général pour
la communication quelques jours plus tôt
le tout à huit mois d'une élection
présidentielle qui s'annonce
particulièrement délicat
[Musique]